c'est pour rendre hommage à l'engagement
de toute une vie que la présidente du
conseil départemental a fait le
déplacement jusqu'au chu de belles
pierres à l'honneur tayeba moulant cadre
infirmière et plans de l'association le
sourire de l'enfant et vice président de
la maison des parents de l'océan indien
car durant toute sa carrière
professionnelle tayeba n'a eu de cesse
que de vouloir donner du bonheur à des
milliers d'enfants hospitalisés ce doux
la réunion mais également ceux de la
zone océan indien met toute son énergie
au service du goût et c'est ce que
délicat comme d'autres ont fait le fou
et aujourd'hui je crois qu'en même temps
on honore un engagement de carrière on
vit même saveur particulière de morez
travail bénévole que les associations
et la principale
malade de la zone 2
de trouver les conditions que les api
de le redonner le sourire à la wii
les réunionnais sont déjà engagés c'est
nassimah dindar sa marraine qui lui a
remis son insigne de chevalier de
l'ordre national du mérite
j'aimerais encore moins de vous recevoir
ici aussi à suivre au côté de cela deux
ans et d'accepter cet insigne de madama
président qui si tu veux planer d'assima
sur le tapis nassima puisque maintenant
tu es ma marraine est aussi situe elle
modèle beaucoup de la maladie nom de
tous les combats c'est sûr que le métier
d'infirmière ci pourrait aider les
personnes en souffrance
et pas n 1
ce métier d'infirmière que j'ai
versée pendant de nombreuses années j'ai
été aussi cadre infirmière et
à la suite de ça je me suis engagé dans
les associations
sous des airs de l'enfant depuis
facteurs 80 et maison des parents de
l'océan
des plus de lui un engagement au sein de
l'hôpital et dans la vie associative qui
n'a pu se faire qu'avec le soutien de
ses enfants mais surtout de son époux
l'époux de retour à cette médaille
puisque comme elles l étaient dévoués à
cette cause donc c'est une grande fierté
pour les enfants et moi même on n'est
pas un moment important et une
reconnaissance également pour l'hôpital
et une cérémonie qui prend une saveur
particulière puisque david gruson qui
sera ses fonctions dans quelque chose
qui a beaucoup donné pour l'hôpital à la
fois comme professionnels hospitaliers
carrière professionnelle et
responsable associative l'association
sourire de l'enfant vraiment très
présente au quotidien fait des enfants
de la pédiatrie du chu avec les actions
exemplaires qui sont menées
hospitalisé à la vie de tous les jours
le sourire de l'enfant le sourire d'un
enfant tayeba moulant continue devraient
pour améliorer la vie des enfants à
l'hôpital car malgré une retraite bien
méritée elle poursuit ses projets en
direction des enfants hospitalisés